hey everyone and welcome to my tutorial
on how to make an origami dragon in
order to make the dragon we first need
to make the bird base which is something
that I go over in my crane tutorial that
you can find in my origami playlist on
my channel I will go over how to make
the bird base in this video also however
I do recommend that you check out my
crane tutorial if you'd like to learn
how to make the Japanese crane what
you're going to need for this tutorial
is a plain sheet of printer paper and
scissors are going to be optional once
you have those items you're ready to
begin so we first need to have a piece
of square paper so what you do with
printer paper is you take the corner and
you line this edge up with this edge by
folding this corner down here then you
make a crease and you cut off the excess
paper okay so now we need to fold the
paper in half by taking the top edge and
aligning it with the bottom edge make a
crease open the paper and then we're
going to fold it in half going the other
way again take the top edge bring it
down to the bottom edge make sure it's
lined up good and then you make another
crease so now you should have a piece of
paper with a cross in it and a diagonal
line so take the paper and fold it on
the diagonal line and just make sure
that it's flat put the paper down on a
hard surface or a table top and what you
want to do now is you want to lift up
the first layer and we're going to tuck
this corner down where my thumb is and
it should go on those folds which you
just made then you can flatten it out do
the same for the other side so lift up
this first layer tuck the corner in like
that and just flatten everything out on
the folds that you made previously
what we're going to do next is to work
on what's known as the petal fold which
is the final fold that we're going to do
in order to get the bird base so to make
things a little bit easier to see on
camera I've drawn a vertical line from
one end here to the other bottom end so
what we want to do next is we want to
take one of these layers and we want to
line up this edge here onto that line
and then we crease so you should have
something that looks like that then you
want to do the same thing with the
remaining three flaps now that we have
something that looks like a kite what we
want to do is to take the top of the
kite and we want to fold the corner down
onto the top of these folds here so if
you picture this as a line you want to
fold the corner directly on that line
just like that and then we're just going
to fold it the other way also alright
what that does is it just helps you do
the petal fold make it a little bit
easier so put the model again on a hard
flat surface open these flaps which we
previously fold it in and then what
we're going to do we're going to lift
this top sheet this top corner and we're
going to pull it upwards and what we
want to do is we want to push it outward
so that these ends these corners here
start to go towards the center of the
model and you might have to push a
little on these folds which we
previously made
so you should have something like that
and what you want to do is just make
sure that the structure is completely
flat flip it over and do the same and
there you go you have the bird base okay
so now that you have your bird base you
want to take these two top points and
you want to hold one in each hand and
you want to pull on them until the top
of that structure goes flat so now
you'll see that the top of it is flat
and then what you do is just flip it
over and put it down like that now what
we're going to do is we're going to just
flatten these two triangle structures
that are sticking up so what you do is
you just take your thumbs and you kind
of push in on the middle of this like
this and you want to just squash it
completely flat just like that turn it
around and do the same thing for this
side so just push in on it like that
and then just press down and then what
you want to do so you should have
something like this then what you want
to do is you want to just take these two
and just flatten them to the right side
and push down make sure everything is
flat and you should have something that
looks like this okay so you want to hold
the model like this with these two arms
facing downward this way then what you
do is you flip the model over completely
now as you'll see I drew another line
that indicates where the center of the
model is what you want to do is you want
to take this edge here and you want to
align it on this line that I have drawn
and then you make a crease do the same
for the other side so now you should
have something that looks like this now
what you want to do is you want to push
down on the middle of this and you want
to fold it in half completely so take
the model now and you should see there
is kind of a fold going this way if you
crease it down you should see it what
you want to do is you just want to make
a fold on that line so just crease it
pretty good turn it around and do the
same for this side okay now what we want
to do is we want to open the middle of
this and we want to lift this piece up
into the middle so it's like this you
want to lift this piece and it should go
on that fold and then all you have to do
is just flatten it out just like that
okay so this is going to be the head of
the dragon and this is going to be the
tail what we want to do is we want to
open this front part and we want to take
these edges here and we want to fold
them down onto the middle line
just like that and do the same for the
left side once you have done that you
want to just close it back up by putting
these ends back together and then you
want to make sure everything is flat
draw a line like this on the neck part
of your model right about there and what
you're going to do is we're just going
to fold on that line something just like
that then you can lift it back up and we
open it we want to just push this part
down on that fold that we just made and
then you want to close the top of it by
just pinching it and you want to make
sure everything is flat then what you
want to do is you want to just open this
top part and you want to fold right
about here so you want to fold it like
that and then you want to just pinch the
top of it again and closed and then you
can lift up this horn here if you want
so now we have formed the head to do the
neck what we do is we just fold the head
down like that and then we can open it
up and we're just going to kind of
squeeze it down there like that now what
you want to do is you want to take these
arms and you want to fold them straight
down so that this is vertical do the
same for the other side okay so to do
the tail if you look at the model you
should see a vertical line that is on
the body of the dragon what you want to
do is you want to take this bottom edge
of the tail and you want to fold it on
that line that's right about there
take it and you fold it up just like
that then what you want to do with the
top is you want to just fold it so that
this part is horizontal right about
halfway just like that
so at 90 degree angles we fold this
directly up and we fold this to the
right at 90 degree angles then you can
just unfold it and what we're going to
do is just open the tail and we're going
to push it up like that just like we did
for the head on that fold and then you
just flatten everything out now that we
have the other fold there what we do is
we just open the center of this again
push down on that fold
so you sit up something like that and
then you could fold it just once more
directly upwards do the same thing you
don't have to be too neat about it
something like that then all we have to
do is to fold the arms by taking it and
folding it towards the center of the
body upwards that way and you want to
fold it just like that so that this edge
actually is on the bottom of the body
right about there
do the same thing for the other side
fold it up and this bottom edge here
should be on the bottom of the body here
just like that and then you just fold it
down and then you can just fold these
straight down like that at 90 degree
angles
and what you do is you just pull on the
arms a little bit and you can open the
tail and there you go you have an
origami dragon